[Music]
hello good morning from Munich Germany
in Germany we just flew here from LA and
we're going to be attending Oktoberfest
which is the biggest beer festival and
whole world we're gonna go try the food
and drink they're probably mostly beer
and it will show you how it looks like
we're wearing the traditional outfit
yours is called don't be turned on and
mine is called later later later
[Music]
alright so just enter Oktoberfest
everyone's dressed up apparently you buy
this to girls for the girl here so this
is this the oldest brewery in Bavaria
that's gonna go in there yeah that's
going there
[Music]
we're gonna order some food try what's
over here and we're gonna eat some food
outside as well but probably later when
we're drunker and it's like a mashed
potato perform as a boy
potatoes very chewy I like the texture
report toxic toxic food clothes some
occult
interesting and this is Highsmith just
like the white sausage at the famous you
in Bavaria looks kind of weird yeah
yeah that's similar to normal tosses but
it's clean salty and soft really soft
[Music]
at a half metre breakfast it's so juicy
and so full of flavor I like this more
than a hot dog
[Music]
so I got some couriers with pride I got
lucky seven the curry ketchup goes so
well with the sausage it is literally my
favorite
can't forget the pretzels they have big
and small ones here got a second carrier
they're so good
this time I got it with some bread to
remove to enlist a little different
white smoke is getting pretty cold so
we're gonna hang out in the tent there
around like 10 to 15 10th year it's kind
of like bar hopping you just go to
different tents and drink and eat
[Music]
very duty
[Music]
[Music]